what do you think is making our lives
easier off late
and how do you think the world is
rapidly changing
imagine getting into a car feeding your
destination as the input
and automatically getting dropped off at
your destination
at the same time you sit back and relax
through the ride without having to do
anything at all
physically whoa life has become so much
simpler with all kinds of automation
taking us through everyday life what do
you think is making all this possible
artificial intelligence thanks to
numerous advancements in technology
which is bringing about a lot of changes
in our day-to-day lives
to drive innovation ai is using machine
learning taking things one step
further so what exactly do you mean by
artificial
intelligence in simple terms ai refers
to simulating a machine
with human intelligence and programming
the device to think
and act like humans artificial
intelligence
also called machine intelligence is far
beyond roboz as portrayed by science
fiction
from google search algorithm to amazon's
alexa
to apple siri to self-driven cars ai
progresses rapidly towards a harmonious
future between technology and man
bringing together the best of both
worlds since the machines are
artificially incorporated with
human-like intelligence
and perform tasks as we do it's termed
as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry
solving algebra word problems and much
more
between the 1950s and 1970s neural
networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world
now is the era of deep learning the
boons of ai
undoubtedly ai has changed our lives in
many ways
at number one we have safety factor
there are many fields like defense
mining etc where human health is at
significant risk
ai is the biggest boon in these fields
where a robo
or a drone does the work instead of a
human with the invention of self-driven
cars
ai is aiding at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition
ai helps in effective communication by
processing and
understanding the language spoken by
humans it is also capable of
comprehending the words spoken by humans
and reciprocate in the same way
all this is possible by the voice
assistant feature which the ai bots have
at number three we have daily needs be
it
alexa or apple siri we are surrounded by
various applications that run on ai
fingerprint detection face detection gps
grammarly all these run on artificial
intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket
buying a product online and driving a
car
ai has limited human interaction and
provides various services
in all the unexpected ways ai is helping
humans in the day-to-day needs
at number four we have healthcare ai is
a promising tool for
supporting healthcare administration it
helps healthcare workers and
stakeholders to manage vast amounts of
data
and transform them into potentially
life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the core
with 19 coronavirus
a who report released said that er is a
vital part of the response to this
disease
ai systems are being developed
predicting people's temperatures
and survival rates with more than 90
percent accuracy
one promising approach of ai in the
field of health care is it guides
vaccine design
as covet 19 began to spread globally
machine learning tools were used to
search
immunogenic components of the virus that
would make good vaccine candidates
yet another field where the ml is
significantly evolving is genomics
which is the study of the complete set
of genes within an organism
ai can sequence and analyze dna much
faster
cheaper and accurate than the
researchers ever will
at number 5 we have robus one of the
most amazing inventions by humans that
thinks
intelligently and acts autonomously the
disinfecting robots are playing a
significant role in these uncertain
times
they rove around healthcare facilities
spreading uv light to disinfect places
contaminated with viruses
the benefits of ai robots far exceed the
apprehensions
speaking of role of technology
advancements
artificial intelligence is rapidly
advancing with a lot of computers and
robots capable of doing miracles
though the machines and robots cannot
have human feelings
they can think and act like humans
companies use techniques like machine
learning and neural networks to
accomplish
artificial intelligence which is also
called machine intelligence
in the present scenario considering the
total intelligence
we can conclude that 95 of it is machine
intelligence
and the remaining five percent is what
we call human knowledge
speaking of ai versus human ai has a
positive as well as a negative impact on
us and society
according to some recent studies seven
million existing jobs will be replaced
by ai
in the uk between 2017 and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created
as well a study from mckinsey global
institute
states that by 2030 automation will
replace 400 to 800 million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cause fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries
the biggest challenge is how people
would make a living with these changes
and uncertainty google ceo sundar pichai
has claimed that ai will be more
transformative to humanity
than electricity ever will google even
launched an ai system which bet some of
the best atari 2600 game players
also did you know that the best choice
player in the world is a machine
how would it be when the best doctor in
the world is a machine
the best teacher is a machine the best
architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots
ais and robos will replace fast food
joints and radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
a robot will perform your surgery
it won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field
warning by musk this is extremely
important
um i think a danger of ai is much
greater than the
the danger of nuclear warheads by a lot
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to
just build nuclear warheads if they want
that would be insane
and mark my words ai is
far more dangerous than nukes
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways
not everyone is ready to welcome ai with
open arms
some ai experts like stephen hawking and
elon musk have warned us about the
looming dangers that ai may possess
to humanity they have even suggested
that ai
is likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species
elon musk says that he is close to the
cutting edge in ai
which scares him a lot ai is vastly more
than almost
anyone knows and the rate of improvement
is exponential
he also says that ai is far more
dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat
ai can be harmful to us in two different
ways the idea that ai will become
conscious
and responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes if the super
intelligent ai
more intelligent than us becomes
conscious they will look at humans like
how humans will look at monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey
where one of the most well-known ais
turned terrible
the terminator the matrix and few others
these movies have speculated about ai
that far exceeds the expectations of
its creators and escapes their control
eventually targeting humans for
extinction speaking of the real reasons
to be afraid of ai
there are doctors engineers accountants
judges architects who seek information
from an ei system
they treat this information as it is
from a trusted colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong
ai researchers pride themselves on the
accuracy of results
it is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake
these systems do not fail gracefully one
such incident is when facebook had to
shut down a controversial chatbot
experiment where the two ais developed
their own language for communication
a research was conducted with two
chatbots named alice and bob
focusing on how to negotiate with each
other unfortunately the researchers
found that the bots had deviated from
the actual script and had started
inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left
unsupervised they developed their
machine language which was otherwise
developed to converse with people
that's the scary part of ai neural
networks and deep learning
the developers and researchers working
on this would have no idea what it's
doing
this technology can get complicated and
we have to make sure what we are doing
with it holds value
we must also handle it cautiously
because ai is a direct reflection of us
people should lead and not follow so
here's the question
should we be afraid of ai we all know
that ai is a transformative technology
that we have ever seen in the history of
humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power
it has the potential to be
transformative both for good reasons as
well as for the wrong
however fear of the unknown has always
been the case with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what ai
is ai is defined by the algorithms that
dictate its behavior and operate under
definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness
what if an ai machine starts to have
human feelings and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas
also we don't think that is anywhere in
our near future
pretty much any type of machine can be
used for either good or bad reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop
or pause in a ted talk peter hurst says
imagine you're driving up a mountain and
it's raining very heavily
as you climb into the mountains the rain
is turning into snow
and pretty soon that snow is a white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you
you start skidding you see some vehicle
was coming to crash into you
all this wouldn't have happened if you
paused your journey as the rain was
getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now
that rain will turn into snow soon and
that snow could quickly become a
dangerous blizzard
so we need to pause check the conditions
put in place safety standards
and ask ourselves how far we want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people in
the loop
spot checking what the ai algorithms are
doing keeping people in the loop will
probably
solve some of our most significant
challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier
however evolved these am machines are
they still lack
human empathy and consciousness so
instead of running away from this
technology
we should understand this revolutionary
technology and make sure it is used in
the right way to make our lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning
you can check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program in ai
and machine learning in partnership with
purdue university